صحيفتها ارتس نشرت مقالا يرى ان التدابير
التي اقرتها محكمه العدل الدوليه ويتعين
على اسرائيل الالتزام بها ستكون مصدر صداع
كبير لنتنياهو ووزرائه المتشددين الرافضين
لاي خطوات نحو انهاء الحرب يعتبر المقال
الحكم من جهه اخرى تحذيرا لاسرائيل من
انها تقترب من خرق اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه في موقع ذهيل نجد ان اسرائيل
تلقت ضربه بعد رفض محكمه العدل الدوليه
طلبها الغاء الشكوى التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا بشان الاباده الجمعيه اذ وجدت
المحكمه القضيه معقوله بما يكفي للنظر
فيها
ومتابعتها ييقول الموقع استنادا الى
محللين ان ما خرجت به المحكمه يعقد مبررات
اسرائيل لمواصله حربها ويحد من دعم
حلفائها في صحيفه الجارديان نقرا مقالا
جاء فيه ان اسرائيل قد تتجاهل حكم محكمه
العدل الدوليه لكن سيكون من الصعب على
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا فعل ذلك يوضح
المقال بالقول ان تجاهل الحكم يقود الى
التساؤل عن الطريقه التي يحاسب بها بوتين
من هنا يتبين ان العداله لن تكون عداله
حقيقيه اذا ما اقترنت بازدواجيه المعايير
حسب الستريت جورنال لا نهايه في الافق
للحرب بين اسرائيل وحماس في الصحيفه تحذير
من ان تصطدم اسرائيل بمع تنتج عن الاصرار
على تحقيق هدف القضاء على حماس بعيد
المنال كما يبدو من خلال احتلال يطول
لاراضي غزه يحول القوات الاسرائيليه الى
هدف لتمرد طويل الامد سلط تقرير في مجله
لوتون الضوء على معسكرات الجيش الاسرائيلي
ومراكز الاعتقال التي وصل اليها الاف
الفلسطينيين من غزه منذ بدايه الحرب يعرض
التقرير شهادات عائدين منها واجهوا اشكالا
متعدده من التعذيب وسوء المعامله وينقل
مخاوف جماعات حقوق الانسان من استمرار
الاعتقالات في صفوف المدنيين وغياب احصاء
موثوق للذين تقده القوات الاسرائيليه الى
مراكز الاعتقال في صحيفه التليغراف تقرير
تناول مخاوف بايدن من كلفه سياسيه قد
تترتب على دعمه لاسرائيل اذا استمر عدد
القتلى من المدنيين الفلسطينيين في
الارتفاع في الصحيفه اشاره الى تقارير
تتحدث عن حث بايدن لنتنياهو على انهاء
الحرب قبل الانتخابات الامريكيه قال محلل
للتلغراف بشانها ان ضغوط بايدن في هذا
الاتجاه ليست مفاجئه فالانقسامات تهدد
بالحاق الضرر بقاعدتها الانتخابيه التي
اتكا عليها في عام